all over the world
species clash in nature's savage battle
of survival
on the rolling savanna
the heights of the andes
and the rivers of australia
all are locked in deadly conflict
animals fight tooth and claw to win food
territory
and rights to the bloodline
from the jungles of africa
to the canadian outback
there are no rules
this is animal fight night
[Music]
some animals don't share their space
they avoid a mutually assured
destruction
[Music]
in the seas off northern australia one
such predator prowls
it's not a great white shark
or a killer whale
[Music]
it's the largest reptile on the planet
covered in tough scales the armor-suited
saltwater crocodile fears nothing
the hyper-carnivorous killer has the
strongest bite in the animal kingdom
escaping from the clutches of his
three-inch teeth would be the equivalent
of bench-pressing a pickup truck
he's the most aggressive of all the
crocodiles
[Music]
in the ocean keeping to himself is
easier
specialized salt glands in the tongue
excrete excess salt without dehydrating
the crop
so he can spend weeks in the open
reaches
but when he comes inshore to breed
competition brings out his killer
instincts
on australia's east alligator river
one huge croc guards his favorite spot
like an armored knight at his castle
gates it's the perfect perch for
attracting a female's roving eye
a cruising croc thinks he's king of the
castle
and wants the plot for himself
which means
getting medieval on the occupier
the king goes low
but the resident knight goes high
lifting his head
means gravity gives his downward strike
more force
matching bites apply intense pressure
around the neck
rows of raised scales cover the length
of the king's back
they're his heavy armor
inside plates of hard bone called
osteoderms help prevent penetration even
from the most powerful bite in nature
but salt water crocks have no bony
reinforcements on the underside of their
neck and limbs
and protruding legs are an easy target
for a well-placed bite
the king snaps
he's locked in stalemate
the knight changes tactics and takes the
battle below water
a sudden jerk
threatens amputation
it's too much for the king croc
and he flees
seen off by the night of the east
alligator river
not all animals seek solitude
some prefer to team up and create an
army
but when two tribes go to war
keeping together can be the key to
survival
despite their slender frame african wild
dogs are some of the deadliest predators
on the continent
[Music]
in packs of up to 40 strong
they target prey twice their size
and kill
four out of five
they run down their victims
and eat them
alive
[Music]
but get separated from the pack
and you risk being left behind
[Music]
fights between related packs are rare
but if strangers arrive
and threaten the local food supply
it can spark a turf war
these intruders know they're in hostile
territory
[Music]
a three dog vanguard keeps tight
formation
[Music]
one breaks ranks
and heads straight
into an ambush
[Music]
the home pack charges in at up to 44
miles per hour
the tactic scatter the intruders
and pick them off
one by one
an isolated intruder makes a break for
it
[Music]
but runs into an unexpected water hazard
five sets of jaws pin him down
like prey
three dogs target the head
pound for pound an african wild dog's
bite is stronger than any other canine
on the planes
but even upside down
he can snap back
until a local disarms him with a lunge
to the neck
well-developed temporalis and mosquito
muscles apply nearly twice the pressure
of a human bite
[Music]
the move prevents the straggler bending
his neck to deliver a bite
42 teeth wrap around his throat
one inch canines threaten his jugular
the dog is in the grip of death
but the hound on head duty loses focus
and let's go
the intruder's jaws are back in play
[Music]
but once again
the terrain slows him down
and the mob moves in for the kill
with the intruder dealt with
the pack seeks other targets
[Music]
this dog has had his day
and the local scavengers
won't have long to wait
being the biggest puts you at the top
but staying at the top
can be your undoing
it's high summer in yellowstone
breeding season for america's largest
land animal
the bison
this standout hunk of beef is a bull in
his prime
right now his testosterone levels are
doubling
the sex hormone is a natural steroid
that keeps him sexually charged and at
peak performance
a power packed one ton titan
it takes a beast of a heart to keep
beefy pumped up
the average bison heart is nearly eight
times the size of an adult humans
and can move an incredible amount of
blood around the body
and it's not just any blood the bison's
testicles are in overdrive creating huge
quantities of testosterone
which increases muscle mass and
aggression
when he fights the release of adrenaline
from the adrenal gland sends more oxygen
to those pumped up muscles
and it's this hormone cocktail that
gives the bison the boost he needs to
fight off his rivals
it makes him the ultimate fight night
heavyweight contender
the females are ready to mate
and beefy wants the ladies to himself
but a gathering of rival suitors
presents a clear and present danger
his growl is a warning
[Music]
all through the season
big hearted beefy takes down his love
rivals
each victory prolongs his time at the
top but the physical cost is brutal
after weeks of heart pounding action
one last love rival is defiantly
seductive
it's a red rag to the angry bull
a male bison will stop at nothing to
maintain its dominant position
[Music]
a downhill charge makes the most of his
weight advantage
his massive 75-pound head
smashes into his opponent like being hit
by a family car
the love rival braces
and pushes back
brute force won't cut it
beefy brings out the heavy artillery
the horns
beat the uppercuts
it rips through fur
but not flesh
head to head
they're evenly matched
so beefy needs a new tactic
a broadside lifts the lothario off his
feet
and out of contention
but a season's victories catch up with
him
battered and bruised
he'll be no match for the next contender
and he retires from the fight game
even so
he has ensured his legacy
his work is done
hunger is a powerful drive
but it can lead to a predator taking on
prey
out of its league
this is wolf country
[Music]
but the wooded shoreline of canada's
lake hatchigan is also home to a north
american giant
the moose
armed with broad 40-pound antlers a bull
moose is a hard target
even for a wolf pack
but a smaller moose cow
could be a very tasty dish
a pack works together on large prey
tearing it flesh on the rear and flanks
the result worn out wounded
wolf chow
a moose cow feeds in the lake to build
up reserves for winter
moose are the only member of the deer
family that regularly feed on aquatic
vegetation
they can even dive remaining submerged
for over a minute
a few yards offshore the lake also
offers safety from any passing pack
her massive six-inch hooves make
excellent paddles
she can swim at six miles per hour
at around six times the weight and
almost three times the height of a wolf
she doesn't fear a solo attack
a lone hunter disagrees
this solo wolf has left his birth path
to find a partner
and start his own bloodline
he's not the type to look a gift moose
in the mouth
but this maverick moose is as cool as
ice
she stands her ground to protect her
rear and flanks
then attacks with huge pointed hooves
a clean shot could kill
but she
overshoots the wily wolf cuts inside
a snap to the sinews
makes her spin
and leaves her body open
his teeth sink into the triceps at the
top of the forelimb
the muscle is vital for walking and
swimming
a severe wound would make her lame
unable to escape
backward pointing canines lock in place
bringing 410 pounds per square inch of
jaw pressure into play
tearing through the muscle
her attacker hangs on
[Music]
and shears through the tough muscle
[Music]
but the maverick has a trick upper
sleeve
she finds deeper water
and sinks to her knees to submerge her
opponent
if the wolf gets trapped beneath her
he'll drown
she's a moose on the loose
once again
this ambitious go-getter was ultimately
out of his depth
you become the head honcho for a reason
finding out why
can be deadly
some animals
command respect
this adult male tiger is in his prime
and he knows it
his stats say it all
his bite generates up to 520 pounds of
pressure
he's armed with long razor sharp
retractable claws
and a swipe so powerful
it can smash a skull
he'll defend his territory against all
intruders
and this one is believed to have killed
other males that he's discovered on his
turf
550 pounds of claw and muscle
but every generation brings a kid with
attitude
the youngster makes himself at home on
the big guy's turf
when he hears the dominant male
it's too late to run
local rangers suspect that this 200
pound heavier male killed two of the
younger tiger's siblings
[Music]
now
he faces the same fate
tigers are solitary creatures
finding another male on their territory
will not be tolerated
with no chance of escape there's only
one option left for the smaller tiger
total capitulation
the larger cat circles to intimidate and
assert dominance
the crouching posture is submissive
[Music]
for the dominant male it's not enough
the younger male tries to push off the
angry killer
big mistake
on his back the odds are stacked against
him
the big guy brings his key weapon into
play his deadly 520 pound bite
out gun and out of position
there's no chance of escape
in any fight between two killing
machines there's a risk of a costly
injury
even in victory
and you don't stay at the top by taking
dangerous risks
he's demonstrated his dominance
and neutralized the young male
for now
among male zebra
the right to breed has to be won
adolescent males fight among themselves
to establish status
unaware they're being watched by a
seasoned pro
on the african plain a new generation of
zebra emerges
they can normally walk 15 minutes after
birth
run within an hour
and they need to
as the savannah is filled with dangers
by the age of four the feisty male
survivors face a new challenge
breeding
but first they need to prove themselves
among their peers
they battle other bachelors for the
right to challenge a stallion for his
harem
they don't have horns or claws or a
battering ram head
but four years of running from predators
has given them hind legs so powerful
their kick can kill
during the breeding season the
grasslands become a battleground for
would-be champions
bites and gouges are standard
goes
even below the belt is up for grabs
a hard bite to the lower leg tendons
could [ __ ]
this challenger specializes in hair
pulling
a mouthful of mane
sees off his competitor
in fight after fight
would be contenders leave it all on the
plane
but when a dominant stallion decides on
a pre-emptive strike
it suddenly gets a lot more dangerous
he has a harem to protect and wants to
assert his dominance over any would-be
challenger
and with everything to lose he won't
hold back
he goes airborne
to coil
and fire
with twice the impact of a heavyweight
boxer's punch
it stuns his opponent into defeat
he follows up with a final sneak attack
to see off the young bachelor
point proven he'll return to his harem
safe in the knowledge
that he's still the top stallion
the easier a kill
the less energy predators need to waste
but get the strike wrong
and wasting energy will be the least of
their worries
it's a hard life being a warthog
to survive they need to grow up fast
an abandoned burrow gives this mother a
refuge for her young family
piglets start out defenseless
but as they grow their tusks develop
making them a much harder meal ticket
these tuskers can turn on predators and
charge at 34 miles per hour
warthogs aren't worried about not being
beautiful
their problem is
they're delicious
leopards find them lip smacking
these big cats are skilled ambush
predators
they kill with a bite to the neck
but in challenging conditions their kill
rate can be as little as one in twenty
they'll often target small game
or even scavenge
anything to survive
[Music]
this hungry young male needs to eat
every three days
a baby hog would be ideal
he sees their pharaoh
adopts pounce position
and weights
when the dust settles it's not a
defenseless piglet it's an older angrier
and heavily armed tusker
she could kill this cat
the confused big cat fluffs the kill
shot
the young hog was in his reach
but at the last second an older hog
dashes out from behind
and blocks the path of the hunter
[Music]
instead of a piglet his teeth find a
determined tusker
he's bitten on more than he can chew
his 1.3 inch canines can't contain her
he clamps down with his paw
but this hog won't go quietly
the porky powder keg hauls her attacker
in a bid for freedom
the leopard counters with a head throw
but it brings her tusks into play
a gash to the throat could kill
[Music]
he needs to get this hog on her back
[Music]
he gambles
[Music]
shifts his jaw hole
and piggybacks his prey
he's now open to an upward tusk thrust
but he uses his 100 pound body weight
to flip her over
belly up
it's the killer move
the leopard hoped for an easy meal
but ended up
with the fight of his life
[Music]
even predators need to watch their backs
because catching
and keeping
are two different things
130 feet above the water
an osprey scans for prey
[Music]
he spots movement
he hits the water at 44 miles an hour
armed with perfect feet for fishing
two digits facing forwards one backwards
and one that can change orientation
his talons snap shut in two hundredths
of a second
roughly 12 times faster than a human
blink
an impressive catch
which hasn't gone unnoticed
a great black back gull the largest of
all goals watches from the shore
an opportunistic predator and scavenger
there's little it won't eat
its main weapon is its curved bill which
it uses to stab smash and tear
[Music]
and it's not above a little piracy
the gull lines up an interception course
and attacks
at the last second the bird of prey
takes evasive action
the goal's persistency is more than a
match for the osprey's maneuverability
and the gaul knows it
and ruthless pirates
the osprey's faster than the gulf but
weighed down by his fishy cargo he can't
escape
the pirate changes tactics
it goes high
to dive bomb its target
[Music]
the osprey tires
the gull moves in for the kill
the bird of prey tries to shake him
but the pirate is ready for it
and grabs his wing
out gunned
and exhausted
he drops his catch
and to the victor
go the spoils
south america
the andes
[Music]
the cunhas live at a high altitude
but when they fight
they sink to the lowest depths
[Music]
this dominant male vicuna never lets his
hair on the female stray far
he has three jobs
keep his family safe
well fed
and father as many offspring as he can
but this is bandit country
full of rivals
[Music]
this young upstart is ready to steal
himself a family
but only if he can get past the current
head of the family
who has a nasty trick up his sleeve
[Music]
he strikes low and fast to [ __ ] an
opponent where it counts most the family
jewels
saving his clan
and seeing off a rival
the frustrated bachelors hang out in
large herds
they hone their combat skills getting
ready to challenge for a family
it's the vicuna equivalent of boot camp
[Music]
training is continuous and compulsory
these two males are evenly matched
they both weigh around 110 pounds
their tactic of choice head butting
and fighting
always looking for an opportunity to get
at the soft underbelly or genitals
[Music]
suddenly one of the pecunias changes
tactics and pile drives his opponent
it's a risky move that leaves him open
his opponent seizes the chance with a
canine crunch
back on the ground
he exposes his principal assets
lose them
and no lady vicuna will give him a
second look
he's lost
but he's learned
and can still be a contender
on the african savanna titanic life and
death dramas play out in plain view
but hidden in the continent's
rainforests the conflict takes a more
sinister turn
there are ten thousand millipede species
in the world
but the biggest of them all
is the giant african millipede
who comes armed with a secret chemical
weapon
he's the articulated juggernaut of the
forest floor
he reaches up to 12 inches long
upwards of 60 pairs of legs slip his
slinky frame through the undergrowth to
dine on rotting vegetation
he's flexible
but tough
calcified layers of chitin form a hard
protective exoskeleton
it's the same chemical that creates
lobster shells
heavily segmented he can curl tight to
create a shield against attack
but he's also got a secret deterrent he
can use in an emergency
each segment of the millipede has hidden
repugnatorial glands
when provoked these secrete his own
personal chemical weapon
a foul smelling noxious liquid that can
repel predators
this dark shell giant is mostly
nocturnal
foraging in daylight makes him easy to
spot
and he's caught the compound eye
of a hopeful assassin bug
he too is equipped
for chemical warfare
[Music]
giant african millipedes are the largest
of their kind
but for the assassin bug size isn't the
problem
it's the giant's armor
[Music]
the millipede tries evasive maneuvers
his shiny shell helps him slip free
but the bug is relentless
he seems immune to the millipedes
chemical defense
and hunts for a weak spot on the
millipedes underbelly
his curved clawed tarsus is sharp enough
to grip onto the smooth round surface
while a specially adapted proboscis
searches for an entry point in the
region of the millipede's legs
he then injects his own chemical weapons
paralyzing toxins and digestive enzymes
that begin to dissolve the millipedes
innards
[Music]
the millipede curls tight
[Music]
but it's too late
[Music]
the process is irreversible
[Music]
this millipede assassin bug lives up to
his name
and turns his adversary into one long
liquid lunch
males can fight tough
but when females go to war
the killer claws come out
dinosaurs still walk among us
or at least
cassowaries make it easy to believe
these flightless forest birds are the
second heaviest and third largest on the
planet
they sport a bony keratin covered ridge
up to seven inches high called a cask
much like crested dinosaurs
even their key weapon seems prehistoric
each foot has a killer claw on the inner
toe
which can grow over four inches
like a dagger an accurate strike can
kill a human
we don't know who ruled the roost among
the dinosaurs
but with cassowaries it's the females
females can be twice as large as the
male
[Music]
and fiercely independent
it's the male who builds the nest
incubates the eggs and raises the chicks
while the female finds other males for
mating
and dominating
this boneheaded bruiser keeps a beady
eye out for rivals
if these angry birds cross paths
it's
fireworks in a park in northern
australia a sassy cassowary emerges
and mounts a charge
it's an epic
fail to the forest floor a smooth tarmac
path is like ice beneath her clawed feet
her rival sees her chance
but the incomer extends her dagger claw
and stabs at her opponent's breast
two of the cassowary's toes have a
carrot and tip sitting at the top
but it's the third digit that is the key
weapon it has a unique killer claw made
of bone that is sheathed completely in
keratin making it extremely strong
incredibly sharp a well-placed hit will
penetrate the skin and dig deep into the
flesh potentially hitting vital organs
but even a miss can be deadly the
downward stabbing motion of the leg can
rip huge gashes in any adversary
the home bird retreats
another slash by the invader
brings her down
but she stumbles at the last second
before she can push home her advantage
giving the home bird the chance to flee
but if they meet again
she'll be a much more wary cassowary
[Music]
you